si moi je dois me le faire toi aussi tu
as droit de le faire tant qu en fait que
john tu fais quoi avec lui pour
l'important c'est pas ce qu'on fait
qu'est ce que ça me fait mais ça c'est
quoi si les tiennent des tombes ou la
bible
[Musique]
iluv rtük risquera pas de liesse
sa mère presque obligé pas non
et oui je connais bien les choses que
nous parce que je serais fait une croix
dessus stress j'étais peintre grâce un
entretien d'une bouche abondamment et je
passe un entretien à un entretien
d'embauché fils étienne gens d'en bas
ces personnes n'est pas ma connaissance
non et parce que vous n'avez vous pas
fait depuis longtemps un ouais c'est
quoi comme mon père c'était pas pour le
moment tout va gérer ça pour voir
comment embrasser pour les nuls non non
c'était vraiment genre pour les fêtes tu
vois gens pour les faux bois les animaux
genoux les mains sera la palatine is
money qui rejoint le bout des doigts
après une semaine à la piscine et les
[Musique]
vas-y tu dis moi un bon argument pour
que je tombe le fait tous les couples
font tu vois c'est un truc de fou
si on fait passer c'est grave qu'on fait
ridicule c'est pas un bon argument si
lestienne de tomber tête baissée
inventive et précis il était déçu mais
c'est bon ballon c'est magique qui s'est
bien passé tout du passé
mais
allier
[Musique]
le volant mais je vais reprendre tout ça
pour rien mais comme je pensais que
c'était bon que tu fais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]